and first of all boris johnson disagreed
with a very famous muppet in his address
to the un
kermit the frog
sang
it's not easy
being green
you remember that one
i want you to know that he was wrong
so how easy is it to be green
let's ask that to jocelyn london first
of all so boris johnson clearly trying
to encourage other countries to go green
but is he right to say that it's the
easy option
um i think my question would be if it
was so easy to be green why boris
johnson since the paris agreement in
2015 has um contributed four billion
plans to the oil and gas industry um
that's not very green uh why is he not
cancelling the campbell oil field up
near scotland um so if it is so easy to
be green why hasn't boris johnson
himself made kind of the most pressing
green decisions uh for this country
bruce what do you make of that do you
think that's fair i mean boris johnson
would no doubt argue that the uk has a
good record on cutting back on its
dependence on coal he'd say that they've
got world-leading climate targets
they're going to announce their strategy
on meeting them in the coming weeks do
you think it's
fair to criticize the uk's record on
this and should boris johnson actually
get some credit for what's been achieved
this week
i think it's a story of two tales one is
yes there's progress but there's a lot
more needs to be done right if it was as
easy as jocelyn said
we wouldn't have this conversation and
so the opportunity we have is how does
government how does boris johnson how do
governments around the world help people
accelerate this transition from fossil
fuels because it's not as easy as it
should be to help transition to electric
cars to electric key pumps there's
enormous things we can do but we need
the government to be helping make it
easier than it is today okay so let's
take a look jocelyn shall we at what
that means for the consumer and and how
easy that could be and we'll have a look
at what boris johnson actually said he
said we have nothing to fear and
everything to gain from the green
industrial revolution so justin what do
you think at the moment of how easy it
is for a consumer to go green and what
will they gain
i think there are some obvious changes
that everyone can make that we've heard
time and time again eating less meat
taking more journeys by foot or by bike
flying less and obviously those are
quite easy actions to take but the more
infrastructural
decisions that we have to make to be
more green are in the hands of the
government and are currently not as easy
as they could be uh we don't have an
amazing and affordable transport network
for people to you know maybe not drive
to work or um depending on where they're
living and so i think there's a lot more
to do infrastructurally from the
government to make these decisions
easier so again as bruce said it's a
tell of two stories there are some um
actions that we can take that are really
simple really easy and everyone should
be doing them but a lot more to be done
systematically well yes and bruce do you
agree with that is this down to
governments to try and make some of
these decisions uh more attractive and
cheaper as well josten was talking about
transport but there's also the cost of
insulating and heating your homes as
well isn't there is it down to the
government to make that cheaper and
easier for us
that's right i mean obviously there's a
lot we can do as individuals we can um
do a lot of things in our daily life but
we're not going to solve this problem
unless we get
governments and businesses stepping up
to make this easier for everybody so as
you're thinking about things like when
your water heater breaks is there a
program in place to help people afford
to make the transition to a clean
non-fossil fuel alternative those kind
of programs rests with the government
helping make sure those programs are in
place and that's what we need across the
world today so that we can get this
problem solved in the next 10 to 20
years yeah and joycelyn bruce mentioned
corporations and companies there what
role does the private sector have
the role of the private sector is to
make sure that they are working in line
with
the targets that we have as a community
this is this takes all of us and um
companies at the moment aren't taking so
much responsibility and are more
interested in greenwashing consumers um
instead of actually being truthful being
honest and making the hard changes and
the hard decisions that they will have
to make in order for us to reach the
goals that we need to
is it that the truth bruce that
ultimately it's going to make good
financial sense to go green we heard
boris johnson talking about it being the
lucrative option
is is that true to say that that's
ultimately going to help encourage
businesses to take that course
i think that's one of the most exciting
developments in the last five to 10
years which is the price of clean energy
today is cheaper than fossil fuels
thinking about the gas crisis in the uk
and around europe right now the
continued reliance on fossil fuels is
terrible for our climate but it's also
terrible for our economy um so you see
factories having to shut down because
they can't afford to buy natural gas
that wouldn't happen if we had a clean
renewable economy and so there's
enormous upside today
the problem is we have um private
companies who are
lobbying on behalf of oil and gas who
are trying to slow down this transition
and currently the governments are
listening to them more um than the rest
of us but bruce there are jobs in those
industries as well aren't there and
people are worried about losing those
jobs
enormous i grew up in the northwest
england and i go back to visit my mom
and it is amazing to see the wind
turbines right those are real jobs
making steel putting them in the ground
and operating them so yes there are
enormous upsides
economically but also for the job
transition so that people have good
family supporting wages